this is the fatness spectrum a small fat  is a size 18 and lower 1x or 2x i'm a  4x5x i'm a size 26 sometimes 28. i am  the super fat you say i'm speaking over  i am the super fat that you say i'm  speaking over so she's responding to  someone on tick-tock and presumably the  person on tik-tok is saying don't you  dare speak over someone who is fatter  than you  you shut up you because yes you you  might be fat  you might identify as fat  but there's someone who's fatter and so  you need to shut up  and then this girl responds she says no  i'm super duper fat i'm the fattest girl  there ever was so i'm you shut up i get  to speak over you because i'm the really  fat person but you know what  there is going to be someone fatter than  this lady go to  some  pacific island somewhere  find some big samoan fella he will be  fatter